empower engage defy defy my favorite
word is engaged everyone's got a
reaction to Isis at aj+ we don't just
inform and tell you the news we want to
hear from you Malcolm in one word is
love resilience what we do does defy
what a standard a news organization
usually does what kind of size balls do
you need to have to say run a 9.5
billion dollar enterprise but still call
yourself a nonprofit what
what's everybody j+ its new it's fresh
it's the next generation of news what's
exciting about the news today is being
able to bring other voices into the
conversation if I was a white dude for a
day I wouldn't really run into any
issues during the daytime I know my
right you got a gun pointed at me I am
NOT committing a crime hearing back from
people I think is important we tell
stories in a unique way you want to hear
about the stories that matter to you